you get criticized a lot and you get
judged for being you know just a nerd or
just a good student not necessarily
smart or bright you really need to fight
to prove yourself to prove that you
really deserve it i felt i needed to
excel or you know i will not really be
appreciated i needed to be on top and i
graduated by the way i was top of my
class when i graduated so it felt like
there is no other option it's either
you're the best or you're not really
acknowledged for your
you know for your achievements
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20-minute leaders and meet
sarah levy the cto of site diagnostics
sarah joined site to build and lead its
technology dream team she's responsible
for site's product and its medical
regulation activities top of her class
at the elite salpiot program sarah
gained her technology leadership
experience during a brilliant military
career where she commanded elite cyber
security and intelligence special
technology units
sarah holds a masters in condensed
matter physics from the weizmann
institute of science and a bachelor's of
science in physics and mathematics magna
laude from the hebrew university in
jerusalem
sarah levy welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for joining me today
how are you i'm great thanks for having
me
thank you very very much for joining me
a chief technology officer of side
diagnostics
the the company reminds me of a little
documentary that i recently saw which
was interesting so obviously we'll touch
on that but i'm i'm sure that it's very
very far from yeah from the documentary
about about theranos but
solving yes but but solving nevertheless
a really really important issue that
inevitably is going to change the way we
experience um diagnosis especially with
blood work so so sarah before we even
get to that you have a really
interesting journey of your own tell me
a little bit about your career and how
do you end up working at side
diagnostics okay sure so actually i was
born in france in a city called toulouse
um to an israeli father and a french
mother and when they graduated their
density studies they made aliyah they
came back to israel with me and they
raised me and my two brothers in the
north of israel
so i grew up in the north and i
at the age of 18 i joined a military
program called talpiot i guess
you heard about it um
a little bit yeah so it's a highly
exclusive program i mean training 40
cadets more or less selected from many
many candidates to become technological
leaders in the security sector and it
involves a bachelor's degree in physics
and mathematics and a wide-ranging
military training and after three and a
half years i graduated telpeot and i
joined the special technological unit of
the intelligence corps
where i spent over six years
and led complex and strategic projects i
mean top secret projects involving a
variety of technological disciplines
and i managed the cyber security
department which back then i think
employed some of israel's best software
engineers some of them very very famous
today
um and incredible but by the way sarah i
just have to ask you how many how many
women were in your topia to year in your
cohort so it was me and another
woman graduating out of 33
back then
and i think these are the numbers more
or less two to four what was that what
was that experience like because i'm
sure that also today being the chief
technology officer of a of a truly deep
tech company it's it's not trivial yet
and that sucks right it needs to be
common and it needs to be equal but it's
not yet so so what is that experience
like for you so i mean obviously there
are not a lot of women it started in
high school well i was in a in in a
class that studied physics and and we
were like four girls out of you know 40
people students in the class and later
on in telpeot it was like a natural um
a natural um
thing to to spend time with mostly with
with men
i think that back then it was pretty
rare for women to study physics and
mathematics and and excel in that it's
becoming more and more common um it was
unique it's not a trivial experience
also the combination of
um sort of you know military training
combat training we had four months off
of uh basic training in the beginning
with combat fighters
and then you know
um officers course and and parachuting
and artillery and all motors and all of
that um it was unique it was an and a
very interesting i would say experience
i i feel that from from building
leadership skills it was very
it built me it was a good you know to
build my strengths and my ability to
deal with with stress with with a lot of
you know competition
um but it's not for everyone
so it's a struggle i mean you you get
criticized a lot and you get judged for
being you know just a nerd or just a
good student not necessarily smart or
bright you really need to fight to prove
yourself to prove that you really
deserve it i felt i needed to excel
or you know i will not really be
appreciated i needed to be on top and i
graduated by the way i was top of my
class when i graduated
so it felt like there is no other option
it's either you're the best or you're
not really acknowledged for your
you know for your achievements
incredible i think that just that that
is so awesome
and
you know i obviously it speaks volumes
to the remainder of your career and and
the reason why i wanted to start and
understand a little bit about your
mindset because you know the things
you've done are are really really
incredible and and inspiring and so now
i understand a little bit about the the
way that you're thinking through the
different challenges and adversities
well what was your sort of strategy
shaping your career how did you sort of
strategize through the different things
that you were going to do later on so i
think that when you sign for 10 years in
the army at the age of 18 you're not
really you know building any real
strategy or just
kind of flowing with it and i wasn't i
mean i wasn't even sure i want to study
physics or i want to have this type of
career i had a dream to become a doctor
which you know in in a way i kind of
close the circle with the company that
we've been building
um
so nothing was necessarily planned
i think i'm a real achiever
and i i try to lead wherever i am so the
career in the army kind of shaped
shaped my ways through whatever came
after
and also i think that it was during
those years in the army that i met some
of the smartest people i know and work
with me some of them work with me today
outside some of them you know open doors
for me so it was mostly organic and by
you know getting in touch with the right
people jumping on opportunities i'm also
very much uh you know i i make decisions
out of intuition of stuff you know in a
way less rational more emotional in a
very rational world
so it just happened
yeah i love it okay talk to me about
site diagnostics and and and also here
it wasn't you you know you started out
um not as chief technology officer and
you overtook that role after you've had
a you know i'm sure a great time with
natural intelligence amongst other other
opportunities
as well as whitesman institute doing
your masters but
what what was it about side diagnostics
that really you know triggered you to
join them early on no i was i mean i was
approached by yossi the ceo of side
agnostics whom i actually knew from
talpiyot i was his first commander in
the army so we met actually yeah wow
yeah i was here oh that is so cool yeah
his first two weeks in the army i was
his commander so that's where he knew me
from
and he offered to join and i think back
then they they had a terrific story
about how to help the developing world
with malaria diagnostics that's how site
started using computer vision technology
to diagnose malaria which is still i
mean the most fatal um
death cause in in sub-saharan africa
it's a huge problem in the developing
world and that was exciting for me to
take part in such a journey so i think
and there were like five or six of them
back then in a sort of you know
garage mode in jerusalem
and it was just very exciting extremely
small people a great story a great goal
and if you're categorizing sort of even
before we get deep into what agnostics
is doing now i want to delay for a bit
on this art of working with brilliant
people and and you know i think that
that really sort of exemplifies your
journey and what you're doing inside
diagnostics what
what what is some what does this lead to
you know obviously everybody wants to
work with good people but being around
really really intelligent people that
all that some of them also went through
similar educational experiences to the
one that you went through what does that
do to a team in your opinion
so i it changes i mean the different
cultures i would say of brilliant people
i think that what i've been trying to
build here at site in the you know in
the first five years i kind of recruited
everyone so i had a direct impact on
this
it's a culture where you really value
the talent and you build a a work space
where you solve complex problems
together but you also value each other
it's a very nice and accessible kind of
environment everyone's nice to everyone
everyone's here about solving problems
about creating value about changing the
world not just not about ego not about
showing how smart you are not about i
think when everyone's brilliant
you just know you're working with the
best people and you're here to do the
job you're not here to impress anyone or
to show off and this is amazing
and also i think another thing is that
i think brilliant people well money is
always important and salaries you know
they're good in the high-tech industry
but i think the two most important uh
aspects uh in a company in in you know
for employment for those kind of
brilliant people are the people they're
working with
and the challenge
and if you have a real challenge a real
deep challenge that can impact the world
and you build you know
an ecosystem of smart people this
attracts more and more talent
and it's more i mean it's much more than
money and compensation in my opinion
one 100 100
side diagnostics today if you had to
articulate the vision
you know in just a few sentences what
what is side diagnostics aiming to do
today to the world and to sort of
humanity if you will well we were
we started from malaria but as a matter
of fact we site was created to provide
patients with access to accurate
convenience and pain-free diagnostic
testing
and and we deliver results in minutes
instead of days
and the way it can transform health care
is by providing
much better and faster
diagnosis to sick people
so that really is our vision to be able
to provide this access and by using our
unique technology to digitize blood to
turn you know a liquid samples that can
be blood but it can also be we're
looking into other spaces as well today
to to photos to images we're actually
you know transforming samples to data to
visual data
so this allows us today to to perform a
complete blood count which is the most
common blood test worldwide the most one
of them you know cornerstones of every
diagnosis process but looking forward we
have a huge amount of data we capture
you know a thousand images of a
patient's blood from every blood sample
and this paves the word the way for our
future applications around prevention
diagnostics precision diagnostics we're
working on biomarkers and on algorithms
for treatment monitoring for early
disease detection and this really is the
future to be able to access accurate
blood test testing at the point of care
whether it's your doctor's office a
pharmacy a clinic a pediatrics
hospital and then by running this
routine test it gives you value you know
digitizing your blood to allow future
analysis and even more insights so
that's where we're aiming beautiful
two different
uh challenges that need to be overcome
right there's the consumer behavior the
actual user experience yeah now there's
there's trust there's behavior there is
you know deforming a habit there is the
ability to understand what is you know
why choose this over something else and
then the second piece of it is the
technology and how we're leveraging you
know new technologies that are available
to us you know artificial intelligence
and and and the ability to really you
know understand
our center blood in a new way
what is
let's start with the consumer behavior
piece how do you
sort of see through as you're developing
the product
what what is this shift in consumer
behavior that needs to happen and and
how do you think it will happen
i mean in in the past 20 years we see a
serious trend of transferring
diagnostics
from their central labs and you know big
centers to the point of care
decentralization is a huge trend and it
has i mean we don't need to educate the
market about this there is tons of
literature about around this many many
companies are working in this space
telemedicine is part of it i mean you
want everything in your house if
possible if not close to your house you
know affordable convenient and to to and
i think the coveted pandemic also
emphasized the need of you know
providing access in the community to
testing we have coveted tests everywhere
but you know if you could have a
complete blood count alongside your
cavity test you could
assess the severity of the disease and
you know how you how you um respond to
treatment and so on so the importance of
decentralization
is felt today globally i really think
that the pandemic is like the lesson of
everyone about this and and everyone
sees value in this and now the challenge
remains technology
because the existing technologies for
some of the tests couldn't allow this
decentralization for decentralization
you need it to be smaller affordable you
know convenient and still as accurate it
needs to be equivalent to what is being
run in central laboratories you cannot
compromise this and that's the big
fear about decentralization that
eventually accuracy would be compromised
and then you know you you get you you
don't you know you you're losing this
trade-off so
by intro by using computer vision and ai
we actually introduced a new technology
to complete blood counts which allowed
to preserve and even in some cases you
know be uh better than what's currently
considered that you know the
the um the lab grade solutions and the
gold standard and and making it
affordable and accessible and simple
extremely simple to use
as a community with no compromise i
think that's the big breakthrough this
is why patients and you know operators
clinics will actually adopt this
solution
incredible and on the technology front
as you're working with the team
leave as the technology leader how do
how do you see your role in this whole
revolution and i'm calling it a
revolution because it really is sort of
a revolution what is your role as sarah
levy in this whole operation so today
i'm leading um what we call them in the
product group the the group that defines
the requirements the priorities and
shapes you know the the pipeline of our
products the program group which manages
the programs the project the execution
of these plans and the quality and
regulation activities in our space in
the medical industry regulation i mean
is is very very much tied to the product
you need to have a real regulatory pass
and to understand the regulatory
limitations and requirements because
it's a highly regulated industry and
it's highly important it's a strategic
element of your solution
so i'm actually paid i mean
shaping the strategy and the roadmap of
the company that really is my role and
i'm trying to on one hand i mean i
i view um the user aspect the user
experience i give a huge value to this
in our industry sometimes it's not
considered of that you know it's more
popular in the consuming the direct to
consumer kind of solutions and and i
think we put a lot of importance to the
design into the user experience
especially around simplicity so i'm
trying to shape a user friendly as much
as possible a user-friendly product and
in the i mean in parallel building the
infrastructure for
data
um our data collection our data growth
we have terabytes of images of blood and
this you know paves the way for the
future applications so my role is to
shape an excellent product that users
will enjoy to use that will be adopted
you know in in in hundreds of thousands
so that we have the amount of data we
need for that for the future promise
what does that do to you you know
internally you know working on a problem
like this working on a product like this
how are you
sort of perceiving your own day-to-day
so first time i'm enjoying i'm enjoying
the role enjoying i love the company i
feel i have a direct impact on on
everything that we do and it excites me
but maybe i mean personally i believe in
discerning my personal views and
and
opinions i believe in the freedom and
autonomy of individuals and in
emphasizing freedom of choice
people in my opinion should have their
own choice in all fields of life
specifically in managing you know their
health
i feel that there is true alignment
between my personal beliefs and the
values through which site operates site
emphasizes the importance of patient
centricity in all that we do people
should own their own data make decision
on where and where and you know where
and when they go through diagnosis and
take a proactive role in leading their
own care
so i feel that in in that way this
really you know resonates with my
personal beliefs and and you know the
journey that i'm doing with sight
where do you derive the the inspiration
either technologically
or
um
or leadership wise as you go about
continuing to build this great company
tackling some
incredible challenges both on on
consumer behavior regulatory you know in
terms of the technology obviously you
need a lot of inspiration to go ahead
and do that where do you derive your
inspiration from well i think i i mean i
was inspired from several leaders i
encountered through my career uh
some of them in the army i think the
motor in the army where where i served
was um you turned the impossible into
possible by you know
using knowledge
and dedication
and uh and will you can change the
impossible into possible and i think i
mean this was the motto and there were
some leaders that really inspired me
with how to achieve that i also think
that um i'm inspired by some women
leaders i think that today this you know
i'm not a big
i would say
classic feminist in just you know hire
women and have like a women culture i
think
their their a balance between you know
female leader and male leader creates a
very interesting and holistic culture
and and and i there are some i mean
female leaders that i look up to and you
know cave the word the way for me and i
i hope to to be looked at you know by
other young women that you know think
about their career um and also i think
sarah i just have to
pause and say for a second that not just
young women i'm looking at you and i'm
thinking about my career as a source of
inspiration so it's not not just young
women yeah yeah yeah i hope so as well
and and also i think i mean well i'm a
technologist and i lead technology but
um i actually view myself as a leader in
general and i look up to many sort of
leaders whether in the education world
politics
i mean i i don't necessarily identify
myself only with technology and i hope
to be to have you know more
opportunities in the future to to show
you know other and to to participate and
contribute to other areas in the civil
world and in you know in education
sarah thank you very very much best of
luck with diagnostics thank you thank
you for serving as an inspiration first
to me and obviously to so many more and
now and later on and best of luck with
you know making humanity better with
diagnosis and with deep technology i
love it and i'm inspired and stay safe
and stay healthy thank you thank you
thank you very much for having me here
[Music]
you